ونتابع المشهد في اسطنبول معنى من هناك
موفد العربيه طاهر بركه طاهر اهلا بك معنا
ايضا كما استمعنا في تقرير الزميله روان
هي انتخابات مفصليه بالنسبه لتركيا تدخل
فيها الدوله التركيه قرنا جديدا ما الذي
لمسته حتى الان هل هناك حماسه بين الاتراك
لهذا الموعد الانتخابي
اهلا صهيب طبعا هناك حماسه كبيره الذي
لمسته من كل الذين تحدثت معهم من كل مختلف
فئات وشرائح المجتمع انه يعني هم متشددون
في ارائهم لا تلقى الكثير ممن لا يجيبك عن
سؤال من
لمن ستصوت يقولون مباشره اما اردوغان بشكل
حاسم ونهائي او كمال كليتش بشكل حاسم او
نهائي الا ان الفئه المتردده طبعا موجوده
وقد يكون لها عامل الحسم في هذه
الانتخابات النقطه الثانيه باختصار التي
لمستها عندما نسال هؤلاء انه البعد ليس
فقط متعلق بالزلزال او بالاقتصاد او بجيوب
الناس وفواتير الطاقه انما ايضا بالمواضيع
الهوياتيه القياميه التي تؤثر في المجتمع
التركي موضوع المحافظه والتحرر موضوع
الدين موضوع القوميه والثقافه والى ما
هنالك نعم ماذا عن الزلزال طاهر الزلزال
المدمر الى اي حد هو مؤثر وحاضر في احاديث
ورغبات التصويت هل هو عامل مؤثر اكثر ماذا
ايضا عن الاقتصاد والظروف والاقتصاديه اي
الامور التي تشغل بال الاتراك اكثر
وتجعلهم يصوتون لصالح هذا المرشح او ذاك
مما تقوله استطلاعات الراي معظم استطلاعات
الراي والمحللين والمراقبين هنا انه
مواضيع الزلزال والاقتصاد على اهميتها الا
انها لا تنال الحظ والاكبر من مما يريده
الناس مع تقدم الايام الزلزال اثر في
الفتره الاولى ولكن تغير مزاج الناس بعد
كل هذه الفتره حتى بموضوع الاقتصاد يعني
الناس تعودوا على هذا الموضوع منذ اكثر من
ثلاث سنوات صحيحه ان المعارضه تقسو بشده
وتقول وتنتقد بان الحكومه فشلت في اصلاح
الاقتصاد مع وصول التضخم الى 85% في
اكتوبر الماضي مع فقدان الليره في خمس
سنوات يعني الجزء الاكبر من قيمتها ل 80%
مع فقدان الناس لمداخراتهم مع غلاء
المعيشه والى ما هنالك ولكن من هو صاحب
نزعه متشدده مؤمن بحزبه وبتياره لا يابه
كثيرا في الواقع الا انه هذه العوامل قد
تؤثر جدا في المترد او في من يريد التغيير
بما ان اردوغان وحزب حكموا العشرين عاما
الان صحيح طيب طاهر على ذكر الاحزاب حدثنا
اكثر عن المرشحين طبعا في الصداره
اردوغانو لكن ماذا عن التحالفات والاحزاب
خلف هذين الاسمين الرئيسيين بالاضافه الى
الاسمين الاخرين
بالنسبه الى التحالفات الرئيسيه كما قلت
صهيب التحالف الاساسي هو تحالف الجمهور
بقياده حزب العداله والتنميه بزعامه رجب
طيب اردوغان الرئيس الحالي طبعا ويضم معه
الحركه القوميه بزعامه دوله بهجلي اضافه
الى حزب الرفاه الجديد ابن فاتح اربكان
نجم الدين اربكان الزعيم الاسلامي الشهير
ويحاول ان يستقطب اردوغان من خلاله ايضا
اضافه الى العامل الكردي المحافظ المتشدد
ايضا من خلال حزب الدعوه الحره او هدى بار
مرشح هذا التحالف هو رئيس الجمهوريه
التركيه الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان التحالف
الاخر الاساسي هو تحالف الامه تحالف
المعارضه الذي كان احد مخرجات الطاوله
السداسيه التي كانت تضم بشكل اساسي حزب
الشعب الجمهوري بقياده كمال كليتش دار
اوبلو مرشح المعارضه مقابل اردوغان ويضم
حزب الجيد او الخير بقياده ميرال اكشينار
والتي كانت بشده ترشيح كمال كلتش دار
اوغلو بالمناسبه اضافه الى احزاب اخرى
مهمه ولكن الاهم فيما بينها هما المنشقان
عن حزب العداله والتنميه علي بابا تشان
رئيس حزب الديمقراطيه والتقدم
واحمد داوود اوغلو زعيم حزب المستقبل
وايضا يعني هذه كانت ضربه البعض يصفها
ضربه بمقتل لاردوغان وحزبه بانه حزب الشعب
الجمهوري وتحالف الامه استطاع ان يستقطب
هؤلاء لكي يكسبوا الصوت المحافظ او
المتدين شكرا جزيلا لك طاهر بركه مباشره
من اسطنبول
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات